[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone
i'm mihaila i'm a research engineer at
deepmind hi my name is ferial i'm a
research scientist at deepmind
i'm also on the board of women in
machine learning my name is kate parkin
i'm a recruitment lead
and i look after all engineering and
research recruitment
i'm generally a very curious person and
i like to
tinker and think about things that might
come up next
and the new possibilities for the
machine learning fields are
very very exciting at the moment i feel
like my research is something that i
would do as a hobby if i had another job
it played to my geeky side it's pretty
phenomenal
we're trying what we can do and what we
can leverage through artificial
intelligence and machine learning
[Music]
i had a lot of doubts whether i i sort
of am suited to join the mind i guess
many women and minorities feel the same
because we don't see a lot of us around
i i was indeed
often questioning myself as in terms of
oh
should you apply do you think you will
be good enough
while internally you have these
emotional
reactions the objective reality is that
there's an interview process
there to decide whether someone is good
enough
optimize your cv to the best that you
can ensuring that you kind of really
pull out those
technical skills at the top of your cv
uh you're really getting across
your background your skills your key
achievements i think networking does
have its advantages and i definitely
encourage
uh women to network as much as possible
i would highly recommend
refreshing your basics understandings of
machine learning computer science
focus on breadth rather than depth if
you're researching just make sure that
you know your basics for
linear algebra calculus probability you
can choose which language you want to
code in
i chose python some people choose c plus
plus
it's quite flexible if there's anything
in addition that you want to tell us or
really highlight
you know cover letters are lovely to
read because ultimately they are
getting across someone's real passion
and desire to want to work for deep mind
you know we're not putting people in an
interview setting
to find out reasons not to recruit them
we want to put them in a comfortable
setting to find out the best reasons to
recruit them
i think during the interview process i
was very conscious of
i guess being a woman not having done an
internship at deepmind before
i felt like i maybe don't belong um
but throughout the interview process i
think
after like talking to researchers and
seeing that i can hold the conversation
and i can sort of answer
questions i felt more confident i
actually went in uh with my
three-month-old son they just
understood instantly you know where i
was at in terms of being a first-time
mum
on maternity very sleep deprived so that
really helped kind of eliminate some of
the self-doubt that i was having around
my own
ability and confidence was actually the
supportive nature of the team
and in the machine learning team this is
of one of the most
inclusive teams that i've ever worked in
it's just a very great atmosphere of
overall growth and actually what's quite
organic about deep mind is actually this
this sort of natural mentoring that
takes place
and that's amongst everybody i certainly
think that certain organizations such as
women that allow
women to get together and discuss both
technical challenges that they face in
terms of research but also
personal challenges in terms of
representation and and so on are very
very important
you do not need a phd to work at the
mind i did not have a phd when i joined
mine i do not have a phd now
you really don't need a phd necessarily
of course that depends on the role that
you're applying for
i think only for research scientists
role you definitely need to have a phd
you need to apply
just apply don't wait for
you to feel like something needs to
click
if you are good enough if you've done
the work if you are confident in your
skills
just apply if you get that tingly moment
when you're reading up about us
uh or we become that kind of niggle in
the back of your head if you're well
you know if you know our research you
should definitely
you're definitely ready